screening for risk of health problems
from obesity to common ways to help
gauge your risk of health problems from
obesity our body mass index also known
as BMI and waist size
BMI estimates your body fat by comparing
your height to your weight you can enter
your measurements into a BMI calculator
or your healthcare provider can figure
out your BMI for you once you know your
BMI you or your health care provider can
find it on a chart to see if you are
underweight a healthy weight overweight
or obese BMI for children and teens is
called BMI for age BMI for age is
calculated the same way as adult BMI but
the child's results are compared with
growth charts adults can evaluate belly
fat by measuring their waist size with a
tape measure men with a waist size above
40 inches and non pregnant women with a
waist size above 35 inches may have a
higher risk of health problems from
obesity if you have questions about your
risk of health problems from obesity
talk to your healthcare provider